ich hab mir gerade über mich gesagt ich
glaube vom auge her könnte auch mädchen
sein ex-klub netz bekommen bayern ein
video
ja wir haben da schon relativ spät
arbeit muss erst mal sagen jetzt habe
ich mich gefreut dass das video ist euer
alter sozusagen erraten hab mir gut
angekommen ist das war irgendwie so
eigentlich mein stärksten fiel bis jetzt
hat mich sehr gefreut dass sie dazu
gefeiert habe deswegen habe ich mir
darauf basierend was anderes ausgedacht
was in dieselbe richtung geht das ganze
gar nicht leider wieder nicht allein
machen deswegen habe ich heute anders
das ist leon vielleicht kennen die ihnen
von ingrid studios ich finde es auf
jeden fall ein süßer kleiner junge im
handy wird ja nicht mehr kleinen 15
hatte wahrscheinlich schon unten am
titel gelesen ich verstehe bis heute
nicht warum der titel und besteht aber
es geht heute darum ihr habt über endler
im ganz viele fotos von ihrem gewicht
geschickt oder von euren augen gemalt
wird nur eure augen sieht oder euer
gesicht ohne haar oder sonstwas und ich
muss halt erraten ob ihr männlich oder
halt zusätzlich muss der rat ob junge
oder mädchen weiß und er hatte ganz
viele fotos rausgesucht die wohl nicht
sterben zum teil besorgt das ganze jetzt
noch zusammen abend gespannt und zu
sagen bei 15.000 gibt es dann die
nächste ausgabe von ich erwarte alter
weil darauf habe ich eigentlich noch
mehr bock als auch das hier aber let's
golf ab 100 eine von ihm und seinen
kollegen ist natürlich in der video
schreibung verlinkt könnte er spielen
vorbei und wir machen das einfach nicht
so ungeschminkt augen nach hier wimpern
geschrieben augenbrauen zu
nachgezeichnet was ist das wohl jetzt
kommt das beste was hacken geschickt
wurde
da ist es schwer alle so könnte ein echt
beiden ja ja so könnte auch ein junge
mit dicken lippen seien ja ihr könnt ja
auch mal auf jeden fall in dem kommentar
mit raten führt jetzt einfach sagen ist
ein junge mein interview da kommt also
es ist ein mädchen priscilla fans ihr
gepflegtes mädchen ist also ich hab ich
will von augen geräte wie kommt man
darauf den hund eigentlich sehr gut war
das ist mega sweers wir aber er oder sie
hat echt geil augen ist das original
auch ein geschickt haben können ist
mädchen mädchen
sie heißt lena an meine haare mehr guck
mal wie ich frag mich warum die so hier
abschied auf der weitere zusätzliche
kämpfer für ab 22
das ist genauso schwer junge bin ein
relativ sicher ist es aber schwer zu
sagen aber nur das auge liter nimmt mir
doch bitte nicht persönlich über also
wenn jetzt im video seit und halte ich
jetzt zum beispiel zu euch sage wenn ihr
mädchen weit dass hier als vom aussieht
wie ein junges ort ich meine wenn ich
mein auge ziehen halte und jetzt mal ran
so könnte doch auch in dieses mädchen
dann da bin ich jetzt eigentlich zu 114
sicher dass das ein junges meint
irgendwo muss ja mal vorkommen reihen
es ist nur ein alters gedacht jetzt
verraten
richtig krasse wimpern irgendwie guck
mal meine wimpern und auch von java
heute ich habe auch vorher still zu
machen weiter weiter immer schön in den
kommentaren mit raten es ganz wichtig
dass heißt schminkt des dino drpic aber
überschminkt gleich gehts los jungs
diesen klick über schnell ab und zu wenn
die volksrechte aber auch so ganz leicht
ich habe ich alte sich dann wenn ich
irgendwie wenn wir irgendwie so ein
fotoshooting oder somit drama mit der
bravo haben der wird ja dann auch so
leicht geschminkt ich sage es um
menschen
der 14 jährige wohnt in berlin der ja
habe ich gut beraten jetzt wird es
schwer hatte
das ist das größte schiff wurde zum das
ist ein junge dann ist da bin ich mir
sicher das ist ein junges mädchen
nein es verlangen dass sich junge sagt
ich glaub schon als ich glaube ich wird
auch junge sagen aber so irgendwie für
die augenblicke perfekt weil ich meine
dass meine augenbrauen perfekt so leute
kommen wir zur foto nummer 7
ich kann mir so richtig bildlich
vorstellen die man jetzt so aussieht und
da einfach ein junge kommt zu dem das
auge passt aber es kann genauso gut
mädchen kommen ja das ist als solcher
aber sie ist ziemlich groß
es ist ein mädchen schwendinger yu-na
für dein neues mittelalter bekommen ist
erstmal zum letzten foto mehr handy
nicht rausgefunden weil der rest tor
einfach zu einfach fällt nicht schwer
kranken bayern sonst sieht man den namen
das ist ja das ist halt wieder das
gleiche so könnt ihr mich gut verstehen
ich kann das wirklich so bei jedem auge
nehmen männliches oder weibliches
gesicht vorstellen er zu dass einfach
damals sagen das ist es jedoch aussehen
junge aber es ist ein junge tut mir mega
light so ich hoffe ihr abonniert mich
jetzt nicht wenn ihr heißt ehrlich ich
hab mir gerade wenn ich gesagt ich
glaube vor augen er könnte ich auch
mädchen seien neue leute schockiert
kräftig mit geraten ich schaue mir mal
die kommentare an und mal sehen wer da
so häufig richtig nicht ich würde sagen
wir sehen uns morgen bei einem neuen
video zeigt auf jeden fall den kanal von
leon und seine kritik und wünschen noch
einen schönen abend
haut rein